>>> WAIT UNTIL YOU SEE THIS.
IT IS A CNN EXCLUSIVE.
OUR CHIEF INTERNATIONAL CHOR
CHRISTIANE AMANPOUR CONFRONTS
IRAN'S FOREIGN MINISTER AND
PRESSES HIM WITH THE FACTS OF
CNN'S REPORTING ON THE SEXUAL
ABUSE OF PROTESTERS IN THE
CUSTODY OF IRAN'S REVOLUTIONARY
GUARD.
LIVE IN LONDON WITH MORE,
CHRISTIAN AN, THIS IS A
REMARKABLE INTERVIEW.
EVERYONE CAN SEE IT ONLINE A
LITTLE BIT LATER TODAY.
WHAT IS MOST STRIKING?
>> Reporter: I, OBVIOUSLY, HAD
TO START WITH THE GLOBAL
CONDEMNATION OF IRAN OVER THE
CRACKDOWN AFTER THE DEATH
AGAINST THE WOMEN'S RIGHTS
PROTEST.
HE ABSOLUTELY DENIED THERE WAS
ANY CRACKDOWN OF, QUOTE,
PEACEFUL PROTESTERS.
HE SAID THE CRACKDOWN GAME WHEN
THE PROTESTS WERE INFILTRATED BY
THOSE SPONSORED BY OUTSIDE, IN
HIS WORDS, WHO WANTED TO CREATE
A COUNTER REVOLUTION.
I BROUGHT UP CNN REPORTING, "NEW
YORK TIMES" REPORTING, HUMAN
RIGHTS REPORTING ON THE
ALLEGATIONS OF MULTIPLE SEXUAL
ABUSES COMMITTED IN DETENTION
AGAINST FEMALES WHO HAD BEEN
ARRESTED.
HERE WAS HIS -- HERE IS THE BACK
AND FORTH.
>> WHEN YOU SAY THE ISLAMIC
REPUBLIC OF IRAN RESPECTS HUMAN
RIGHTS, ONE FEMALE PROTESTER
SAYS THAT SHE WAS DETAINED
INSIDE A REVOLUTIONARY GUARD
FACILITY FOR MORE THAN A MONTH
AND RAPED BY THREE DIFFERENT
MEN.
SHE WENT TO A CLERIC AFTERWARDS
BECAUSE SHE WAS VGS SUICIDE
THOUGHTS, SHE WAS SO UPSET.
CNN SPOKE ABOUT THAT CLERIC.
IS THAT ACCEPTABLE?
IS IT ACCEPTABLE FOR A WOMAN,
WHATEVER SHE HAS DONE, TO BE
ARRESTED AND RAPED?
AND THERE ARE MANY, MANY, MANY
REPORTS OF SEXUAL ABUSE IN THIS
SITUATION AGAINST WOMEN AND MEN.
>> Translator: FIRSTLY, IN THE
PEACEFUL DEMONSTRATIONS IN THE
FALL, NO ONE WAS ARRESTED.
>> YOU ARE JUST DENYING THAT?
>> Translator: HOWEVER, IN THOSE
PROTESTS THAT HAVE BECOME
VIOLENT, SOME INDIVIDUALS, SOME
OF WHOM HAD ENTERED IRAN FROM
THE OUTSIDE, AND WERE USING
FIREARMS AND KILLING THE POLICE,
WERE ARRESTED.
YOU DO KNOW THAT THE SUPREME
LEADER ACTUALLY ISSUED AN
AMNESTY AND ALL THOSE IMPRISONED
WERE RELEASED WITH THE EXCEPTION
OF THOSE WHO KILLED SOMEONE OR
WERE BEING SUED.
REGARDING THE IRANIAN WOMAN YOU
MENTIONED, I CANNOT CONFIRM IT.
THERE HAVE BEEN SO MANY BASELESS
CLAIMS MADE ON SOCIAL MEDIA AND
IN MEDIA.
>> Reporter: THESE ARE NOT
BASELESS AND THEY WEREN'T ON THE
INTERNET.
IT'S CNN SPOKE TO A CLERIC, A
RELIGIOUS PERSON, INSIDE YOUR
COUNTRY AND GOT THIS STORY.
>> Translator: WE HAVE SEEN SOME
OF CNN'S REPORTS THAT ARE
TARGETED AND FALSE.
>> Reporter: THAT'S NOT TRUE.
WE REPORT THE FACTS AND WE
REPORT THE TRUTH AND THAT'S WHY
YOU ARE SITTING WITH ME HERE,
MR. FOREIGN MINISTER.
>> Reporter: AND IT CARRIES ON,
AS I PRESS HIM ON MORE OF THOSE
ALLEGATIONS AND WHAT WE HAVE
SEEN OF ABUSES OF HUMAN RIGHTS
AGAINST THE WOMEN AND
PROTESTERS, BUT ALSO OF COURSE I
ASKED HIM ABOUT HELPING RUSSIA,
THE ALLEGATIONS THAT THEY ARE
HELPING RUSSIA TARGET UKRAINIANS
DURING THIS WAR AND OF COURSE
ABOUT THE IRANIAN NUCLEAR DEAL.
AND THE U.S. IS NOW SAYING THAT
IRAN MAY BE SOME 12 DAYS AWAY
FROM SO-CALLED BREAKOUT IF IT
WANTS TO CREATE ENOUGH ENRICHE